I thought it would be kind of a nice
thing to do to have a visit from the god
of affection himself
Cupid wouldn't that be a nice idea if we
keep it out here
hi Cupid how are you good hi Conan and
happy Valentine's Day to all the lovers
out there where am i lovers at oh yeah
you know since you're here maybe you
could make two people in the audience
fall in love would that be cool yeah
happy to help
okay everyone raise your hands if you're
single all right raise your hands if
you're single wow that's a depressingly
high number that's a lotta a lot of
single people came here tonight so Cupid
do your stuff here we go booyah yeah all
right we got no yeah it didn't even hurt
oh it doesn't hurt yeah I'll wait to do
now is find him a match that's all we
have to do right now let's find him a
match so just look around and see if you
can find him a match I got one yeah
ready oh no no no oh crap
sorry you hit one of our you hit one of
our cue cards oh did I yeah oh man I'm
gonna be so fired for this can't you
just try again sorry man
no can do I get one shot and once two
people are struck by my arrows they are
destined for each other that's stupid
you can't make someone fall and maybe
it's stupid you are
[Applause]
you can't do that that's okay we were
just leaving
come on cue card let's get out of here
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so what do you feel like doing
[Music]
thanks coded for showing me what true
love really is
[Applause]